thank you
he's walking right now
hey
how's it going well you know okay yeah
yeah
I like this price
this scene for me was the scent that the
real Amy Lachlan had spoken about at
length with me she described how the
Charlie she knew was two different
people one was her friend who saved her
life who was kind and generous and
empathetic and the other one was a
serial killer but she described that she
only met that murderer twice and this
was the first time and how it was a
completely different human being
you ready to order oh oh don't you know
I'll get a I'll get a cheeseburger
me too all right so cheeseburgers please
I have the girls
they're really good
I was a mayor yeah she's great I feel
better
work's been pretty awful without you
there we were like partners
I know
I thought the worst part is that
everyone is just you know
talking [ __ ] about you all the time
I guess they would
it makes me mad cause you're not there
to defend yourself and so you know I'm
going to town on everyone and
Sandra Oh god oh she got an earful now
that you talking [ __ ] about me
you know I don't want to talk about
Parkfield it's
why not
it's a power struggle but it's also in
some sense both characters are emerging
from some kind of shadow in the scene
they both had not been honest about who
they are or what they think so we're
saying something different than what's
happening inside
because
what they're saying is true
the fulcrum of this scene was that
Charlie believed in this person as an
authentic human being and the second
that he questioned her authenticity when
she says I would forgive you if you did
something like that I wouldn't care if
you did those things he knows her too
well he knows that's a lie and that's
the moment when the friendship I think
crumbles in his eyes I mean I could
understand
you could explain
the thing that I remember discovering in
our first take of this was the moment
when Jessica reached out to me and I
smashed and this cheap Diner Cutlery
smashed and it created this violent
thing that actually shot me when you
slammed the table I jumped and then I
went around the corner to where craft
Services were and I did a little dance
to myself because I was so happy because
it's one of the absolute biblical scenes
in the film and it's just such a raw act
of violence but it's so innate it's
against the table and it gives you then
the suspense and attention to carry it
all the way through and I wish I wrote
that moment it's so good
we needed a guy that the audience
automatically and naturalistically could
befriend and wanted to be friends with a
red Maine was exactly what we were
looking for
today's never
told you to speed up as an actor I'm so
used to that on film and I get
absolutely get it that the thoughts have
to come quickly and you have to in order
for it to make it into the edit but so
much of this scene was about the power
of Silence
you're filled with something but you
don't want to show the person that
you're sitting across from what is true
so both of us are hiding until we can't
hide anymore
and I was thinking I know I was thinking
that maybe you and Maya and Alex and
then me and my girls we could go on and
take a trip or something
I want to talk about barkfield
I want to talk about what you did
these takes were long long takes but you
never felt rushed and actually I felt
incredibly relaxed because and it was so
important because there's an absolute
arrogance and institutions to him in
this moment when he claims the time
after she's confronted him
there's a moment like where it's also
like you're not going to break me
probably for both of them the way that
to be as directed is especially like
where you see it's we're shrinking and
even in terms of how much we visually
see if Charlie or or Amy in this because
so much is in the shadows that idea of
two different people a disassociative
quality was something that Christy had
put into the scene so that idea that you
see him flip and you see as Jess was
saying this extraordinary power struggle
which was thrilling to play because it
was about two actors and two characters
trying to retain the power there's like
two things in films that we can operate
with what we hope for and what we fear
and in this case we hope that Amy is
able to stop him and we fear that he
will get away with it right
I gotta get up
starting a new job it can't be great so
I'll call soon
and the interesting part of that point
in a character study is that that's the
character almost being ready to take it
all but haven't learned just that last
thing yet she's Brave to do everything
she's Brave to confront him she's Brave
to do the power struggle with the eyes
but she's not brave enough to admit that
there is a true friendship between them
and not until she was ready to do that
she was ready to stop him and that's
this whole scene
sleeping you guys he's leaving he's
walking all right now is everything
really happened the last scene in the
film really happened the diners it's all
true when I hear a story about a woman's
bravery and that she was this individual
was able to take down this system of
corruption and save people's lives I
wanted to be a part of it the real like
thing that she was left with was this
idea that she had failed that she hadn't
gotten to confess and that to me I
thought was like
you know that shouldn't have ever been
her job to begin with and to like go in
with this this like Zeal in this thing
and I think you play that so perfectly
when I read Christy's script I didn't
know anything about this story on the
one hand it was this real life
superhero story about this woman who did
extraordinary things and it was also a
terrifying indictment of us a system
there were two villains in the piece
there was this man who did monstrous
things and there was a system that
sustained that and it's somehow these
systems can grow out of wonderful places
and ideas but the second that you become
a cog in the machine and with becoming
that Cog you lose a sense of humanity
and the power of the individual then
things go awry and this film was about
the power of the individual
wow